[Music]
the origins of
five common superstitions a black cat
crossing your path
cats have a long history as omens and
are long associated with magic
in ancient egypt they were seen as
harbingers of good luck
and as messengers for the gods their
association with bad luck however
started in medieval europe specifically
in the 14th century
this unfortunate belief became so bad
that during the black death
black cats were often hunted down and
killed in certain towns
as they were thought to be the
progenitors of the plague
in reality this was a case of mistaken
identity
cats were found in towns and cities with
plague outbreaks
because they were hunting an increased
rat population
we know now that these rats were the
true culprits of the plague
and most unfortunately the killing of
cats in these towns made the plague
worse
as the rat population would then run out
of control
cats also had an association with
witchcraft
the fear of witches reached its heights
in the 16th century and it was thought
that witches would sometimes take in
stray cats this caused people to believe
the cats especially black cats were
working with the witches
and doing their bidding or even that
cats were really witches in disguise
this assumption even came up in the
infamous salem witch trials
where owning a black cat was seen as
evidence against
a person suspected of witchcraft
interestingly in some cultures black
cats are seen as good luck charms
specifically in japan russia and some
parts of britain
breaking a mirror will cause seven years
of bad luck
mirrors like cats have had magical
associations for centuries
in some cultures people believed and in
some cases still do believe
that a mirror could steal a person's
soul this superstition originated in
classical rome
mirrors were thought to reflect or hold
a fragment of a person's soul
so when a mirror reflected your image
and was broken
it was thought to signify damage to the
soul as well as the glass
the original superstition was concerned
with natural cracks in a mirror
as mirrors back in roman times were
weaker and had more imperfections than
modern mirrors
so could break due to atmospheric
changes in the environment
the superstition was later expanded to
include accidental breaking as well
romans also believed that life went in
seven
year cycles so whatever luck you had
be it good or bad would be wiped away
every seven years
hence the seven years bad luck
walking under a ladder like some of the
other superstitions discussed
this partly has its origin in ancient
egypt
ladders were seen as pathways that gods
and human souls
would take to come and go from the
afterlife so egyptians were always sure
to be respectful
when dealing with ladders the modern
superstition though is christian in
origin
a ladder was a symbol of the holy
trinity the three sides make a triangle
the father the son and the holy ghost so
strolling under a ladder would be
breaking the trinity
and that would be bad indeed frankly
this superstition is probably the most
useful to follow
as objects and people often fall down
from ladders
knocking on wood knocking on wood is
often used to call good luck
or more specifically call off bad luck
it seems that the superstition has
indo-european and celtic roots
these groups believe that trees housed
spirits so knocking on wood would either
drive out bad spirits or call good
spirits for their protection
in christian folklore wood was seen to
symbolize the cross
so knocking on it would call the lord's
protection this meaning was probably an
adaptation
of the previous mentioned pagan
superstition
after the christianization of europe
throwing salt over your shoulder in
ancient and classical societies salt was
a very
valuable commodity so spilling salt was
a major waste of a valuable resource
and of money because of this it became
associated with bad fortune
throwing the spilled salt over your left
shoulder as an act of
penance was seen to negate this bad luck
in christian folklore the devil was
thought to be just over your left
shoulder
whispering lies and tempting you to sin
so throwing salt over it
would blind the devil and make him leave
you alone
also judas jesus's betrayer
was thought to have spilled salt at the
last supper and since
judas was a major villain in the bible
this
association stuck
[Music]
hello i really appreciate you checking
out my video
if you want to see more like this please
subscribe like the video if you liked it
leave a comment letting me know what you
think and check out some of my other
videos if you want to learn more
bye